what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to this channel called um
I think it's called Sandman it's a mgtow
channel and I just reacted to something
from them the other day and I thought it
was really interesting so we're gonna
react again before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification Bell that we are going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started also guys um before I forget
sorry uh we have a Google form um to
sign up for meet and greets that we're
gonna do in the US and in the UK so if
you want to meet me and some of the team
make sure you sign up to both of those
hi everyone Sandman here I was
originally going to cover a donation
based video today and I have a few of
those to catch up on but instead I
decided to cover the topic of women
responding to mgtow and what one
particular woman has told me about mgtow
and how I've responded to her first I'd
like to read a comment from this woman
named Leslie fetch she was watching some
of my videos and this is what Leslie has
to say these videos are weird as hell I
just randomly found this video and so
just heard about mgtow I think they're
super sexist but in a misguided way
rather than in a deliberately hostile
way so rather than feeling like it's an
attack against women I feel like these
certainly biased due to a lack of male
responsibility for things facts are
presented in an emotionally neutral way
that comes across as very genuine so in
one way I'm concerned about the message
being sent but appreciate the absence of
hostility towards females I am intrigued
I mean I've seen scholarly articles like
this except with the gender reversed
where a woman says men are nothing but
problematic and then say in a very
serious way that all women should
essentially become lesbians at least
until we can solve the oppressive gender
Dynamics these types of Articles go on
to say that sex with a man can be
nothing but violent which is insane I'm
not saying that women aren't sometimes
responsible for shitty things but I feel
like these essentialist Notions of
gender whether it be directed towards
males or females are harmful to both
sexes now I have a serious question see
okay this when you first listen to mgtow
um you get a lot of arguments like
you're throwing out the baby with the
bath water and you know that it's sexist
whatever but when you really think about
it the reason men are walking away is
because the system's in place put women
in a position where they can they
basically have more power over men
because if a man you know even
approaches a woman he can get me too
right if he takes a girl home and hooks
up with her if he doesn't have CCTV like
footage in his house basically to
exonerate him she can go back and say oh
um he graped me like I talked to a guy
the other day that he had three kids or
two kids with a girl and she accused him
of graping her 10 years ago like that
you know you know I mean it's like so a
lot of times like the way I look at
mgtow is like the guys are just like
logically problem solving if they get
married to a girl have a kid with a girl
she can put them on child support for
life she can put them on alimony so it's
like instead of dealing with women the
guys are just walking away until the
systems change I don't actually think
it's like oppressive towards women or
hatred of women I just think it's saying
that these systems are wrong you know I
could be wrong you know let me know the
guys that support mgtow advocate for
total gender segregation do you really
think women have all the power which
often seems completely deluded to me and
it does on the outside looking and you
would never think that but it's like the
more guys I talk to for this documentary
I'm like God damn damn like women do
have all the power in society like even
politicians guys like women will always
use the argument that politicians
um are mostly men but who are they
catering to the women
um who's the media catering to women who
are churches catering to women because
women make 70 to 80 percent of consumer
buying decisions so all of society is
catering towards women and you don't see
it right away but once you see it you
can't unsee it and how much
responsibility would you say that men
have in the messed up gender Dynamics
how do you explain all the men in high
political and business positions
hoarding money and power and do you
believe in any aspect of the concept of
patriarchy I am a woman I want to be
educated on your perspective okay and
this is the other thing like women they
always see men in the top percentage of
society hoarding money but do you like
women have no idea what cost that comes
with to be in the top one percent of
society those men don't have lives they
don't even have time half the time to
spend the money that they have
um but like women just see them as super
oppressive when really they're super
um needed in society because they're the
most
um how do you say they're the most
productive ones and you need productive
members of society it's not women's like
it's not the men's fault that women are
less productive by and large bridge and
I'm not trying to dismiss your
perspective I truly want to know well
Leslie are we sexist because we refuse
to sacrifice ourselves for women and do
things for ourselves and by ourselves
mgtows aren't deliberately hostile but
instead we're more deliberately passive
aggressive and we're far from misguided
taking the red pill is like seeing
through the dense fog of covert control
and manipulation that women the State
Corporations and cultural institutions
put in front of men to keep us blind
once we see through this fog we realize
that things are deliberately made
complex by women so that we as men can
continue to jump through feminine Hoops
our entire lives what you're seeing on
the internet Leslie is men finally
talking about the bondage that women
have kept us under since the beginning
of time and now we're free and if you
call our freedom sexist figure nothing
more than a tyrant you are intrigued
because we're being genuine rational and
not angry about what we know many women
would throw a temper tantrum if they
realized that someone was oppressing
them the same way that women oppress men
many women have controlled our Behavior
by giving us sex only when we behaved
appropriately that's true and that's why
guys like a lot of a lot of the
conservatives get mad when they say a
woman that makes you wait for sex is
never worth the wait like that's a big
red pill
um manosphere I guess talking point and
the reason they say that is because you
never want a woman that is using sex to
control you like you have to do things
in order to get sex from her because
then you're going to be constantly
trying to appease her where it's like if
it comes from a more genuine place of
she's attracted to you it's just a
better relationship Dynamic like a lot
of a lot of the conservatives get so mad
at that but I understand where they're
coming from based on what the female
collectives agreed to be acceptable
behavior women Dole out sex to men like
dog treats if we take you to a dinner
party or buy that purse or flowers that
you've always wanted then you typically
reward us with your affection love and
sex and if we don't then what do you do
you put us in the dog house mgtow men
accept that this is female nature it's
not a mystery to us anymore and many of
us have seen it long enough to
understand that this is female nature
and getting angry about it is a complete
waste of time do we get angry at a baby
for pooping in its diapers of course not
he's kind of funny do we get upset when
it rains of course we don't instead we
carry an umbrella and for us our
umbrella is the internet our protection
is our knowledge and sharing our wisdom
with each other Leslie you also say that
in scholarly articles many women writers
say that men are a problem and they say
that all women should essentially become
lesbians to me these are women that fear
men and fear our strength if you've ever
gone to a feminist rally you'll notice
that there are many lesbians there
trying to fuel the hatred of men so that
young and naive women run into their
arms into the arms of feminists as men
going our own way we are predominantly
straight males and we don't tell men to
abandon women and shack up with other
men and we don't try to manipulate each
other in the same ways that these female
authors do the you're describing most of
us have loved women and for many of us
this is a painful last step to accepting
the fact that we have to let go of the
dream called love a dream that is used
to keep men boys their entire lives and
Society fears real men because a real
man lives his life for himself and
Without Regrets mgtows feel that Society
is keeping us unhappy and unsatisfied so
that we will basically be more
productive but the truth is we're even
more productive when we're happy yet
Society fears our happiness at least you
think that men are more than just
violent when it comes to sex with women
and some men can be rough in bed and
some women like that but some men can
also be lazy in pushovers in bed and
some women hate that as well it's a
personal preference you also say that
essential Notions are stereotypes of
gender can be harmful to both men and
women women are more collective in their
way of relating to one another men in
society in general because of that women
are more likely to fall into the cliches
of stereotyping men on the other hand
are more individualistic and lone wolves
so there tend to be more in our way of
seeing the world I agree that in some
cases stereotyping can be a bad thing
but when most men have no idea about
female gynocentrism they need
generalized information to grasp the
concepts talking about specific women is
also something that I Do by
incorporating personal stories that I've
lived and that other men around me have
experienced as well and I've talked
about the good as well as the bad with
regards to your serious questions about
mgtow first of all you ask if we support
total gender segregation well we don't
want Total gender segregation and many
of us are content to occasionally date
and have sex with women but we won't
submit Our Lives money or change our
Behavior to accommodate some of the
ridiculous demands that women can put on
us and we seriously believe that women
have all the power because they make up
the majority of the voters yeah and
that's that's oh my gosh when I realized
that it was such a red pill moment where
I was like wow all of society is
literally catering towards women and
to say you don't know I guess on some
level you do but you just don't really
notice as a girl you're just like living
your life but it's like once you see
this stuff you can't unsee it that's
crazy thing and he's not made up of 50
males and 50 females if men die five
years earlier than women there are more
female voters than male voters out there
so therefore women have more political
influence than men I recently spoke to a
woman that didn't agree with this when I
brought it up she thought it had to be
50 50 but it's not this guy is so smart
guys actually this is really good
content this is like well thought out
and in some countries 53 or 54 of the
population is actually female what about
proportional representation for men and
women I'm sure that will never fly
making the male and the female vote
truly equal Leslie you also ask how much
responsibility men should take for
messing up gender Dynamics men these
days are [__] whipped no one likes a
whipped man not other men women or even
children and no one likes wimpy men
either so when men are mangina white
Knights and try to help women and give
them what they want they're actually
messing things up for everyone else guys
are irresponsible for being nice guys
and mgtows are men and not manginas one
of my clients recently told me that I
was an alpha male and that I'm a man's
man and I told her that I've only been
this way over the last year and a half
since I grew a pair of balls and saw
women's Behavior with my faculties of
reason instead of my emotions women
however need to take more responsibility
because they're the majority of the
single parents out there yeah I think
most problems in society are caused by
women and simps that's my opinion yeah
um I just think you can't really argue
with it he's right women are in control
of sex and
um women are the majority of single
month like you know I used to get a
little bit offended by this you know
when they say well women are the problem
with the single parents and I would
think no well the men are sleeping too
like it takes two until I realized that
women are 100 in control of reproduction
and women pick who they sleep with so
it's like if you're picking a guy that's
not a good father that's that's on the
women
yeah it's our bad yeah ultimately
responsible for raising men and boys and
thus creating a situation where those
men become manginas and harm the gender
Dynamics another question you ask is why
are there so many men in high up
positions in business and politics well
the answer to that is quite simple men
make businesses and create as well as
innovate women predominantly manage and
redistribute the wealth and Innovation
that men create men invent everything so
why shouldn't they make the money and
basically keep the power I'm gonna start
saying that actually that's a really
good point men create everything so of
course they're going to have the
majority of the power they built it
that's a really good point themselves
Google was founded by two men and
Facebook was founded by a Man Too the
steam engine was created by a man and so
basically what you're saying is that men
should invent 99 of the things that we
enjoy in our daily life build their
companies and then hand them over to
women men hoarding power and money often
do this because it allows them to
attract and keep females that they find
attractive money and power are also a
means to an end for most men if you want
to be a communist Leslie where men give
away their power go live in Cuba or
North Korea when men are stripped of
their ability to hoard money in power
they stop inventing or caring because
there's no point to working for free you
also ask if I believe in any aspect of
the patriarchy to that question my
answer is the word patriarchy is used to
strip men of their rights by saying that
a man has to share power equally wow
that's such an interesting way to put it
the page I'm gonna say that the
patriarchy is used to strip men of their
rights because they're saying they need
to share power equally not about power
it's about responsibility men are
responsible for making sure the roads
factories buildings and key
infrastructure continues to function but
women don't want to work in construction
and Road repair for the most part and
they don't want I don't no I do not that
is facts sensibility they want to work
as city planners telling those Road
workers what to repair from the comfort
and safety of a desk with regards to the
fictional character Spider-Man his uncle
once said that with great power comes
great responsibility and most women want
great male power but they will
male responsibility at least the
majority of them don't want that
hopefully I've educated you about what
it means to be a mgtow as well as what
it means to be a man but women will
never truly know what it's like to be a
man until they're forced to rely on
themselves 100 percent men don't get
freebies and handouts from each other
if I ask most of my friends to help me
out on a project for free they will
often tell me to piss off however if I
offer them money they'll be there on
time women have the privilege of using
their beauty to ask men for free favors
and there's always a white knight or
mangina out there to do those favors
that is female privilege and men will
never have that that's real that's so
true I've had
yeah yeah that's true I wish I could
have female privilege but I've never
been able to work what my Mama gave me
so to speak try doing everything in your
life without any help and see how that
works for you better yet do everything
for yourself and help the random guy
here and there and do them a favor and
then you'll see that it sucks to be the
average guy in our society when many
women ask me for favors I tell them it
will cost you when I ask them for a
favor they often scatter and hide as
quickly as possible and that's been my
experience men going their own way is
about male Liberation for the first time
in history we're free to do what we want
and we're no longer required to be
providers think of us as the men's
Liberation Society or front anyways
thanks Leslie for your questions and
thank you everyone else for taking your
daily dose of red pills so enjoy the
rest of your day cheers okay I thought
that was a good video actually he had
some really good points and that's the
thing like a lot of times there's this
narrative that like the red pill they're
just angry the mg Tower angry where it's
like you know honestly if you listen to
some of these guys stories
um about losing custody of their kids
getting falsely accused of things you
would probably be angry too so yeah
that's that's my opinion on it and I
really don't think they're angry I think
it's just like men are more logical than
women so men are just like trying to
solve a problem where it's like in every
way that they deal with women there's a
consequence you hire a woman you might
be sued for sexism later yeah you um you
get a girl like you you take a girl home
to casually date her whatever she can me
to you later it's like you marry a girl
she can take half your [__] and I'm not
saying this to be pessimistic it's just
it is what it is and I think the mgtow
guys they're just like logical and that
that's the solution they see I'm not
saying everyone should do it um I think
it depends on the person but I was
speaking to a guy from the documentary
the other day where he got screwed over
in divorce court with he actually didn't
even get married just with um getting
custody of his kids and I said I don't
it doesn't seem like there's any way to
avoid this like he seemed to have picked
a good girl she seemed to be nice enough
right and she still screwed him over and
he he basically said no there's no way
to avoid it you just pick someone and
hope for the best and hope she doesn't
do that to you and that's a lot of power
to give someone
um so and I that's what I think the
mgtow guys are they're just like logical
and I think that's where there's a lot
of like misunderstandings between like
the conservatives and the red pill
because the conservatives are saying
well this is how the world should be and
red pill slash manosphere slash mgtow
we're saying well that's not what the
world is we're here so let me know what
you guys think in the comments and like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and go subscribe to Sandman
I think he actually has really good
content so like the video and I'll talk
to you guys next time